Can you imagine what the word ted would have looked like
if it had existed in the Roman Empire
I think it could be something like this:
a craftsman would have chiseled it
into stone for days in full
sunlight and in the middle
[Music]
there is a monk locked in  his room
would write t&d with his pen
and it would be as far back in time as
these letters would look in the 80's
they would have weird electric colors like
our hairstyles
if this event was about kids
it would be the shapes of the letters
as if they were blocks that fit together
and with bright colors and without changes they were
about superheroes
I would have them say inspired by my
criteria the greatest of all
superman
the shapes of these letters speak
and tell us things beyond what
they write they
refer us to times they transmit
values ​​to us they tell us stories
If we think about one day ours
is full of letters, we see them in
front of the bus on the front of the
bakery on the keyboard on which
we type on our cell phones
everywhere
since the beginning of history
people have felt the  The need to give
language an image and rightly so
because language is the most
important tool we have to communicate
without understanding what a word writes
we can see certain things that are transmitted
there are letters that tell us that later it is
modern at least back in the 70s
There are letters that come to confirm the
magnitude and monumentality of the place and
tell it in capital letters. There are letters that
are not made to last for so long,
nor the opportunity that
they communicate.  The
inside of the place looks like
when I moved in, Olin, I felt
firsthand all the impact that
drawn letters can have on our daily lives
and a new city, and that was
exciting and new for me. Now, dealing with
an unknown language was
very frustrating at times.  and uncomfortable several times they
found me a party clinging to my
glass of wine without understanding a word
of what was said around me
and of course with a smile as I
understood everything
I felt limited in my ability to
say what I thought
I felt
I believed that
not only did I not understand the conversations,
the street was full of signs and
texts that I could not read,
however the drawing of the letters
gave me clues and opened a little window to
understand the little stories that
are enclosed in the way
they recognized which place is the  tradition is
important I did
not understand when someone wanted to give me
an indication in your day that it was
better here they did not pass
and I could see when something was done
forever the shapes of the letters
help you better understand my surroundings and
navigate the city I was recently in
paris  and something similar happened to me after
spending a few days in the city
I was looking for something delicious to take
back home I walked and walked and
walked until I found the
perfect bakery their sign is not true I
see them and still today I imagine the teacher
baker dedicating to each bread the same
time that the artisan dedicated to each
letter of this word
I can see the bread with the
right ingredients being kneaded gently and
carefully in the same way that the
artisan drew the terminals of these
letters with soft curves and  precise
but the master baker placing the
buns on a thin layer of flour
so that the base does not burn
I think of the craftsman putting the
mosaics 11 in the oven taking care
not to run the ink
the master baker's love for detail
is reflected in  the attention paid
to creating this poster
without having tasted the bread we already
imagined that it was good
and I attest it is delicious
I am an electrician and my job is
to draw letters
the same as to prepare the bread
requires care in its preparation a
fair measure  it is ingredients and love
for details
our alphabet is my raw material and at
the same time my limitation the
basic structure of the letters is for me a
playing field where the only rule is that
the reader can at the end of the road read
the message
stop  show you how I work like I
never took bread.
Some time ago I was commissioned to do
the stage of a classic book enlist in
Wonderland'
and it says that there is a burrow and
an absurd journey through a fantasy world began. Do you
remember
in this  occasion the name of the story is
my raw material
at first sight there are things that are not so
important and I can decide to reduce their
size for example in the iii of the it will
have a very small scale later
but some ideas what if to
communicate the idea  wonderfully it will use my
writing in its best expression with
many curls and flourishes here and
there or what if it will be enough for me more in
the fact that the book is a classic and
will be in the form of more
conventional letters making everything look
a bit  more rigid and serious like an
encyclopedia or like old books
or how you could see feeling that this
book makes so much senseless to combine
both universes in the same composition
other rigid and soft coexisting in
the same structure
and I like this idea and I'm going to work on it
In detail, I
am going to take another sheet to work more
comfortably, I mark some guidelines and thus
determine the structure in which these
words will exist.
Oh, and to begin to shape each
letter and work carefully, he dedicated
time to each one without losing sight of it.  The
whole
drew the terminals of those letters carefully, they
are square or round,
they are pointed or chubby and soft,
and he tried various objects where I
try out ideas and change elements, and
there is a point where the drawing
translates into precise shapes with colors,
volumes, and  decorative elements
'alicia that the celebrity is located in
front with volumes her letters many
dots and lines or putting in the background
help me to tell that
many things happen in this story and to represent
this feeling that it generates as if one
were with one's head in the  clouds
and of course this list that looks at this
wonderland'
drawing the letters of this title
I recreate the climate of the text a bit I
let the reader see the story through
the peephole of the door
that's why I shaped concepts ideas
that exist in our imaginary
the idea of ​​the dream of chaos the concept of
wonder
latifa the typography and the shape of the
letters work a bit like gestures
and the tone of voice is not the same as saying
the public of tx río de la plata is
enormous  what to say the public of this
equis río de la plata is enormous
the gestures and the tone are part of the
message
by giving shape to the letters I can decide
more precisely what I want to say and
how beyond the literal text
it can be my favorite bad word  in
a very flowery way
and be very corny when I talk about love
I can speak loud and imposing
in a soft and poetic voice
and I can tell the difference between
Buenos Aires
and Berlin
two cities that I know very well
and it was precisely in Berlin where my
work  it became more colorful, more
expressive,
more precise, telling stories,
everything that I couldn't say at that party,
standing holding my glass of wine,
exploded in shapes and colors on the
paper,
without realizing it, this limitation that
I felt in language became an
engine that drove  to perfect the
tools with which I could
express myself
if I couldn't say it by speaking this was my
way of saying and telling things to the world
then my great quest is to
find my own voice and tell the
stories with the exact tone and gesture
that I want  neither more nor less that is why
I combine colors, textures and of
course letters
that are the heart
and that is why I always want them to have
truly beautiful exquisite shapes
to tell stories by drawing letters that is
my job
and with that it is a reaction in the reader
to awaken him in some way
we do  to dream to move
I think that if the message is important it
requires work and craftsmanship
and if the reader is important they
also deserve to receive beauty and fantasy
[Music]